Ricky Thompson uh first of all thank you
so much for chatting with me I feel like
I'm literally sitting down with the
voice of this generation especially
during this quarantine you've been a
source of light and entertainment and
fun but let me first ask you because
you're human just like the rest of us
how are you holding up in self-isolation
um I'm doing pretty good like literally
like it doesn't even feel like days
anymore or like everything it's just
like all going together so I've gotten
used to being indoors and honestly it's
not that bad like I'm just like the same
positive like okay I can get through
this and yeah you're hanging in there
huh I feel like I feel like it also
helps that you're in a new pad right I'm
so happy to be Cory to like my very own
place I love it it's very nice oh it's a
big book well then you can get to know
the walls the furniture you know like I
know you're using every room in that
house for content and all my right yes
of course yes every single room I'm like
okay I have options and all will get
into the videos you're making then
quarantine and stuff but like what other
activities are you kind of doing the
past the time right now um I've been
doing a lot of at home workouts because
I'm saying like if I leave this
quarantine I literally want to look my
absolute best I've been starting to
learn how to cook because okay frozen
meals I'm just over that so I'm learning
to cook I've been catching up on a lot
of like TV and stuff and watching movies
so pretty much that how's your cooking
game so far stir fry so that's cute
like you know I'm gonna work up some
gourmet meals very soon I love it I love
oh you're still working out because I
feel like the last time I saw you I said
it was at the Streamy Awards I'm like
wait I saw you in Calvin Klein like I
need a lot of video from you and now
we're sweating to the the newbies and
the oldies with you like it's it's
everything again yes yes yes he's like
once quarantine it's done a beach bod
ready huh yes oh my gosh 1,000% I'm so
ready
can't wait you guys not ready for this
well tell me this what is like the one
luxury you miss the most right now since
we have to stay at home um I honestly
think getting like my the most like me
I'm always on top of that I'm getting a
haircut every league
I'm getting my braids to be dead but now
I'm just blowing like this oh and this
is not my favorite I'm like I can't do
anything about it house having that new
dog and everything you thought it would
be or more like has it been there I
didn't realize how hard it would be to
raise a puppy he's literally just like a
baby yeah um but I love him to death
he's everything my best friend took him
for the weekend because she's lived
right by the beach I was like oh my god
she's been in the house whole time so
like no wonder have fun he's in his best
life so what kind of dog got are you oh
my goodness I literally am I never
thought i would be like this crazy dog
dad but what I would do is I look like
my dog on the couch and like I would
shopping with him and I was like it was
actually so weird I was talking with oh
my god you like this dog big dog collar
with this look good with your coat and I
caught myself was like wait a minute he
doesn't know what you're saying like
Ricky calm down like I'm a dog damn I
really want my dog's like be like the
Flies dog out there I have a nice thing
because everything you touch is fly so
you got to get the things to match you
know know why my dog has to match my
style come on talk to me spill the tea
on dating life in quarrel I'm like is it
is your dating life and Quarantine
non-existing right now are you spending
more time up in the DM than ever before
oh my goodness literally I would say it
is like not the best at all I don't know
what it is but I feel like people get me
up I'm just not interested I'm like I
can't go out like I literally don't what
I don't
I hate texting I really hate texting I
hate typing on the phone I rather like
it's like person type stuff like it's
just like not I'm not interested so
you're more of an IRL person you prefer
like you didn't want to waste any time
chatting because you feel like I would
feel like it's going nowhere like I
would need to go out and my schedule
I'm like afraid that if I like continue
carrying on this conversation dispersed
and like what if we get out of
quarantine uh not even talk to each
other like you know I don't have time
for that so like I'm ready for the real
life stuff when you get out of here
though are you gonna be in the streets
like what is the dream man for Ricky
Thompson oh my goodness the dream man
for me I want someone who's really funny
some who's carrying someone who has like
their own stuff whatever you know they
do their own base tucking my own
business um someone who's like I don't
know okay I like really really really
warm up that's all guys I love feeling a
little I'm a giant mess oh so if you
know what it feel like
well listen like I told you you have
become such an impactful voice during
these trying ass times and your videos
are just pure entertainment do you
understand that you're nasty dirty
stinky musty crusty selfish ass it's
passing around dirty germs and it's
affecting a lot of people that's wrong
but you [ __ ] that's what would you say
that how far in advance do you plan to
stuff our do you wake up just with a
burst of inspiration and hit record I
literally like I always say this I amaze
myself I don't know how my mind gets to
that but I wake up I was like oh that's
the cute video I didn't record it and
then it just happened like that like
they got like jot down my video idea
it's like no like all my video do is
just come back to me you're naturally
talented and creative well that's the
thing like I feel like the key to that
your success has been you being yourself
yes yes yes right like that's literally
what I want it'll be one people to
realize you know you can be yourself and
be like huge that it worked out perfect
you're funny as hell like you just say
yeah I just are imitate life like is
this how you are when cameras aren't
rolling oh my gosh yes it's what you get
I'm this person jokes like I always
gonna make sure someone's laughing
around me like that's like my goal in
life won't listen
you got you got celebrities laughing
with you okay you are feeding the world
with your content
Jared Leto retweeted your social
distancing video I mean where you come
up
Agra what oh my gosh I then literally
died so like how I felt about that me
and my best friend Maggie were obsessed
with your Leto and she had called me
like three times I was like oh it's
probably because something kept on
Twitter or whatever and I checked on
Twitter and I was like oh my god share a
little like you [ __ ] up my video and
he goes on Instagram and I called her
it's okay like I just say hey I was like
girl do you close my videos like no I
was like jira Leto and she freaks out
[ __ ] I'm about like I loved your letter
so that was like are you still shipped
by those experiences cuz then you have
like like Miley Cyrus who are reaching
out to you to be on her like Instagram
live show I mean you have very famous
hands like a celebrity oh my god I love
your videos I think like I was get so
excited but now I'm like yeah that's our
friends ha ha you with my leaks I watch
me watch that together it's like you
guys had a vibe going like I live from I
like she's everything I love the how
she's doing this Instagram show you know
keep the paucity alive and it's amazing
so we're living for the content we're
living for you I gotta know what is next
up for the Ricky Thompson Empire what
you got cooking oh my goodness literally
when I get out of this quarantine I am
really ready to take over I'm definitely
gonna be traveling more doesn't doing
more things in fact and I just get out
of his house so I can literally like to
go off you know shine bright because
literally the lot I think one of the
last things you did before quarantine
was you were at Milan Fashion Week
literally before it got crazy literally
literally literally it was so crazy but
we were there maybe like I was like
three or four days before everything I
start again like crazy I just like you
need to go home or whatever I was ready
to leave I gotta go I gotta get back
home like wow that was great Wow
but little did you know that would be
like your last big trip like you don't
know well you do it up right
I will say that oh yeah yeah
I do say that I'm like before all this
went down I went to what was I went to
New York London and Milan so like one
big last trip glad I took that trip I'm
so happy I did because if I do my gosh
wow I missed out your appointment looks
your plan you know you're a fashion icon
in the making I told you you have a lot
of fans AET and a lot of them want to
know are we are we gonna get a Ricky
Thompson twerk before work DVD like is
that oh my gosh workout video I'm like
one I got you know hello Richard Simmons
who hey hey we're healthy weight well
tell me like what are the two or like a
couple or three keys to the to mastering
the twerk I'm gonna do it for you right
now like well hey okay you always okay
get it bring your knees it's gonna bring
your knees okay
I like really arch your back as much as
possible yes yes yes and don't shake too
fast
a lot don't take a lot of a shake too
hard that's a bit too slow but a little
bit more a little bit more arch that
back our step back a little bit fast a
little bit yes I got the stretchy pants
on so that helps too okay but you got it
you got it
I love you you know what's the message
you have for all your fans watching
especially on in our entertainment
tonight oh my goodness okay guys you
know you gotta stay positive stay
positive but they pop it don't be
hitting your head too much no we're
going to get through this we can get
through this together and you know just
check on your friends shoving your loved
ones and you know keep your head up and
we got this
[Music]